[Musique]
l'histoire de vauban est à jamais liée à
celle du morvan sébastien le prestre
marquis de vauban était ingénieur mais
aussi et surtout grand architecte
militaire on lui doit d'innombrables
fortifications quelques 333 au total en
france en bourgogne franche comté
notamment mais aussi 140 participation
héroïque à des batailles ce qui lui a
valu sa renommée militaire il a été
nommé maréchal par louis xiv
propriétaire de très nombreux domaines
entre nièvre et yonne c'est ici dans
cette petite église gothique qu'il est
inhumé une église saint-hilaire de
bazoches qui s'inscrit dans un parcours
touristique pour découvrir l'histoire de
vauban une aventure qui vous mènera
également à saint léger vauban son
village natal
[Musique]
il faut traverser l'église dans sa
longueur pour découvrir le tombeau de
vauban
mort en 1707 à l'âge de 74 ans c'est ici
qu'il repose son coeur a toutefois été
transportés aux invalides à paris sur
ordre de napoléon
[Musique]
qui tombe à auch prenons la direction
d'avalon dans l'yonne
la petite ville sous-préfecture de 8000
habitants a décidé de rendre hommage à
vauban en 1873 c'est là que nous avons
rendez vous avec la directrice de
l'office de tourisme
catherine on est au pied de cette statue
vauban à imposantes statues vauban signé
bartholdi c'est un peu l'emblème entre
autres médailles ballon quand même c'est
quand même effectivement là n de la
ville d'avalon puisque effectivement
elle trône sur la place centrale de la
ville elle est très très présente et
dans la vie également des à ballonnet et
avallon un vieux clichés persistent que
l'on croit que les remparts ont été
réalisés par vauban fait un cliché c'est
un cliché de talent puisque les remparts
en pierre les premiers 1 ont été
construits à la fin d'une neuvième
siècle vauban ineo 17e par contre il
s'en est inspiré pour ses fortifications
vauban nationale qui a marqué l'ensemble
du territoire mais que les touristes se
plaisent à découvrir ici margot vient de
la ciotat pour marcher sur les pas de
l'auteur de la dîme royal ou vauban
exprime sa volonté d'égalité et de
partage équitable devant l'impôt sur la
fin de sa vie comme il a parcouru
beaucoup beaucoup la france et s'est
rendu compte de la pauvreté du peuple
plus je connais sa vie plus je suis
admirative voilà moi parce que je trouve
que c'était un grand militaire c'est lui
qui a créé les premières frontières de
la france il faut le dire mais c'était
surtout un grand humanitaire
pour mieux comprendre encore qui était
vauban dirigeons-nous maintenant en
plein coeur du morvan dans son village
natal saint léger de fougeret devenu
saint léger vauban sur décret de
napoléon iii lui consacre un musée
depuis 20 ans où l'on découvre le
parcours d'un homme pour le moins
atypique
en premier je dirais que c'était un
génie c'était un homme très intelligent
et qui était en même temps un humaniste
un économiste un philosophe et un
écrivain également en 2016 il serait qui
à votre avis
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'il soit
un premier ministre mais bon il pourrait
peut-être un président pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est en 775 deux ans après le siège
victorieux de maastricht et grâce à une
prime très généreuse de louis xiv à
vauban que le maréchal est devenu
propriétaire de ce château un édifice du
12e siècle ouvert au public et encore
aujourd'hui propriété de ses descendants
[Musique]